الى التطورات على الارض وتحديدا في
اوكرانيا حيث قال رئيس دانياسك الموالي
لروسيا
دينيس بوشيلين قال ان حوالي
75% من مدينه بخموت اصبحت تحت تحت سيطره
القوات الروسيه هنا نتحدث عن داخل المدينه
وتحديدا عن سيطره قوات فاجنر على المباني
الاداريه لهذه المدينه وهنا بوسط المدينه
طبعا التصريحات الروسيه والاوكرانيه هنا
متناقضه حول موضوع السيطره الكامله على
هذه المدينه والتي تخوض طبعا القوات
الاوكرانيه فيها والروسيه معارك شرسه في
منطقه تجمع السكك الحديديه داخل المدينه
وتحديدا بوسط مركز بخموت معارك ايضا شرسه
تدور في المنطقه الشماليه وتحديدا على
اطراف مدينه
اريخا في غربي هذه
المنطقه اذا هذه المعارك تدور هنا في هذه
المنطقه على اطراف مدينه بخموت وايضا
ببلده
تحاول القوات الروسيه هنا اقتحام المنطقه
باعداد كبيره من المقاتلين طبعا لقوات
فاجنر دور اساسي بهذه المناطق وبهذه
العمليه لقطع الطريق من مدينه
وتحاول هنا ايضا اكمال السيطره على هذه
المنطقه وقطع الطريق هنا بهذه النقطه
تحديدا لاكمال السيطره على كل مخموت التي
تعتبر تعتبر منطقه استراتيجيه والحرب
دائره فيها منذ اكثر من شهر وطبعا حرب
التصريحات بين كل من الجانب الروسي
والاوكراني موجوده منذ اكثر من شهر
وتحديدا فاغنر بالذات
ميثروكو لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات